[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مناطق مختلفه من العالم تستقبل عاما
ميلاديا جديدا وتود عام 20 22 المطرب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومع دخول العام الجديد
باطلاق الصواريخ باليسيه باتجاه كوريا
الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل الخير وكل عام
وحضراتكم بخير عام سعيد على الجميع
استقبلت مختلفه دول العالم عام 20 32
في استراليا كانت سيدني من بين اولى المدن
الكبرى التي اعلنت الانتقال الى العام
الجديد مستعيده بذلك نشاطها السنوي بعد ما
شهدت في العامين الماضيين اغلاقا
واحتفالات محدوده بسبب تفشي اومترون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد اقل من ساعه على انطلاق العام الجديد
دوت انفجارات في سماء العاصمه الاوكرانيه
كييف وقال رئيس بلديتها ان النظام الدفاع
الجوي يعمل للدفاع عن المدينه من الضربه
الروسيه من جاته ذكر رئيس قائد الاداره
العسكريه الاوكرانيه ان الجيش الروسي قصف
منشات بنيه تحتيه حيويه في خرسون وان
المدينه والبلده المجاوره تركت بدون
كهرباء
وقبل ساعه قليله من بدايه العام الجديد
امطرت روسيا بالصواريخ العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وعده مدن في البلاد رئيس بلديه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف افاده انفجارات في العاصمه
ادت الى مقتل شخص واحد على الاقل كما تضرر
احد الفنادق ورسوله العربيه من موقع
الفندق الذي طاله القصف يطلعنا على
التفاصيل
قبل ساعات من نهايه العام الجديد تتعرض في
اقل من 48 ساعه الى غارات جديده طال القذف
هذه المره مباني سكنيه في منطقه
روسي احد الفنادق في وسط العاصمه حيث قتل
شخص جراء
نتيجه قضايا سقطت لتصيبه بعض المباني
وتخلف عدد من المصابين الذين ننقلوا الى
المشافي لتلقايه الصحيه بلغ عدد الضحايا
اثنا عشر مصابا بينهم مواطن في حاله حرجه
بالسلطه الدمار هنا حيث اقف طال جميع
المباني في المحيط تحطمت النوافذ الزجاجيه
وخلعت الابواب ونائب رئيس مكتب ديوان
الرئيس الاوكراني كريشينكو علق على الهجوم
ووصفه بالهجوم الارهابي وقال ان الرؤوس
تعمدوا استهداف مناطق ماهوله بالسكان في
عطله يا اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه لارهاب
الاوكرانيين وكسر عزيمتهم وقد كانت
الحكومه في حاله تاهب متوقعه هذا الهجوم
كما قال الرئيس الاخرى ان الروس لن يفوتوا
مثل هذه المناسبه دون محاوله ارهاب
المواطنين وتنفيذ ضربات جديده ويذكر ان
السلطات الغد جميع مظاهر الاحتفالات في
كيدز وجميع المدن الاخرانيه وشددت على
الالتزام بحظر التوالي مما يجبر
الاوكرانيين على استقبال العام الجديد في
بيوتهم لقناتيه العربيه والحدث حذيفه عادل
كيف
انا اتقبل ما يحدث وانا افهم ذلك لا اريد
المخاطره بحياتي لقضاء هذا اليوم بالطريقه
التي كانت عليها من قبل حيث تغيرت حياتنا
وعلينا التكيف
يحاولون افساد العمل الجديد كنا نتوقع ذلك
لسنا مستئين
اود حقا ان اقضيها مع اصدقائي المقربين
لذا فهذه هي الخطط الان انا بدي اطلع حقا
الى ان تنتهي الغاره الجويه قريبا ويمكنني
الذهاب والالتقاء بهم
الرئيس الاوكرانيه قال في كلمته بمناسبه
العام الجديد ان اوكرانيا ستواصل حتى
تحقيق النصر مشيرا الى ان بلاده لن تغفر
لروسيا غزوها وقذفها المتكرر للاراضي
الاوكرانيه و بانه لن يتم العفو عن الذين
يامرون بضربه الممثله والذين ينفذونها
روسيه مناطق عند في اوكرانيا منها العاصمه
كيف في عيد الميلاد وراس السنه الجديده
صواريخ روسيه تم توجهها ضد الناس واسفلت
على مقتل شخص واحد على الاقل والعديد من
الجرحى اوكرانيا لن تتسامح مع هذا العدوان
ولن تغفر لموسكو والعالم كله لن يغفل هذا
العمل الارهابي
من جانبه وفي كلمه له بمناسبه العام
الجديد اكد رئيس الروسي بوتين ان الغربه
لم يحقق اهدافه في تدمير البلاد حسب وصفه
واوضح بوتين ان الغربه توقع تدمير الكامل
للصناعه والتمويل والنقل الروسي لكن لم
يحدث هذا على حسب تعبيره واشار بوتين خلال
تهنئه الجنود الروس بالعام الجديد الى ان
الاجراءات التي تتخذوها حكوماته تهدف الى
تعزيز السياده روسيا في المجال الاقتصادي
اكد مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبيه
مواصله الدعم لاوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا
خلال العام الجديد وقلب رويال في تغريده
الله على تويتر ان الاتحاد مصمم على
مواصله الوقوف الى جانب اوكرانيا في عام
بالتخلي عن التزاماتها بحقوق الانسان
الاساسيه من خلال مهاجمه اوكرانيا والامن
العالمي وفقاء تعبيره
ومع دخول العام الجديد اطلقت كوريا
الشماليه صاروخ الباليسيا قصيره المدى في
بحر الشرق المعروف باسم بحر اليابان وقالت
وكاله النهار الكوريه الجنوبيه نقلا عن
هيئه الاركان المشتركه ان عمليه الاطلاق
هذه هي الثانيه خلال ايام ونفذت من منطقه
لعام 2022
باطلاق تجارب على ثلاثه صواريخ باليسيه
وهو عدد كبير لاطلاق صواريخ في يوم واحد
للاسلحه مع تصاعد التوتر في شبه جزيره
الكوريه بعدما اتهمت سول جارتها الشماليه
بتسير خمس طائرات عبر الحدود للمره الاولى
منذ خمس سنوات وردت بارسال طائرات مسيره
نحو الشمال
لا يمكن تحمله كما صرح رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه
بعواقبه وخيمه جراء تلك الاستفزازات
وتعذيذه شبكه الدفاع الجوي لبلاده مع
التاهودي بالتعامل الصارم مع استفزازات في
كوريا الشماليه كما وصفت هيئه الاركان
المشتركه عمليات الاطلاق بانها استفزاز
خطير يقود السلامه الدولي مع تشديد سول
بمراقبته تحركات كوريا الشماليه عن قرب
بالتنسيق الولايات المتحده قوه نوويه كما
يصفها رئيسها كيم جونغ اون فبيونغيان
اختبرت هذا العام اكثر من 70 صاروخا شملت
اطلاق صواريخ بالسيه عابره للقارات تحضروا
عقوبات الامم المتحده اخبارها
ومهما يكون من امر فان التوترات في شبه
جزيره الكوريه واليابان سيرحل للعام
الجديد لتصعيد غير مسبوق قد يفتح ازمه
جديده تضاف الى ما يحدث في اوكرانيا
المغرب يمنع دخول جميع القادمين من الصين
بسبب تزايد اصابتكورونا هناك
اهلا بكم من جديد طلب رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان القاده
السياسيين بعدم تضييع فرصه توحيد الصف
السوداني التي وصفها التاريخيه مشيرا الى
ان الاقصاء وفرض الوصايه من فئات المحدده
سيضيعاني امن ووحده البلاد
والسياسيين من ان الفرصه التاريخيه لتوحيد
الصف
وحده وبناء الدوله السودانيه حصل عليها
الشعب السوداني بعد تضحيات جسيمه فلا
تضيعوها فليس امامنا كثير من الوقت لينتظر
تكرارها مره اخرى
وتقديم دور الاخرين وعدم الاستماع الى
مطالبهم وفرض الوصايه عليه من فئات محدده
من قطاعات الشعب يضيع هذه الفرصه ويضع
وحده امن بلدنا في خطر كبير
كشفت ايران انترناشونال من خلال مقاطع
فيديو حصلت عليها استخدام القوه الامن
الايرانيه للعنف ضد محتاجين تجمعوا
للتظاهر في سوق كلوب دعك في العاصمه طهران
اعتقلت قوه الامن عددا من المحتاجين بشكل
تعسفي بحجه التحريض على العنف ورده
المتظاهرون في سوق طهران المركزي هتافات
الموت القامنائي الموت للديكتاتور
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جاهزهران
في الاثناء حضرت منظمه العفو الدوليه من
تنفيذ السلطات الايرانيه الاعدام بحق 26
محتجا على الاقل مواصفات الامر بانه
محاوله لتهريب المحتجين من جهتها اكدت
منظمه هانجاو الايرانيه لحقوق الانسان
ومقرها النرويج ان ما لا يقل عن 100 محتجا
جرح تجازهم يواجهون احكاما محتمله
بالاعدام
هنا حيث القسوه تشمل الاحياء والقتلى قرار
المحتاجين الايرانيين بمواصله طريق
التظاهرات الشعبيه ضد النظام الايراني
تقابله السلطات باصدار احكام قاسيه بحق
المتظاهرين ليس ذلك فقط بل تستولي عالجت
من القتلى هذا بخلاف احكام القضاء بالسجن
لسنوات طويله والجلد للمحتاجين التي تصفها
مؤسسات الحقوقيه دوليه بالمحاكمات السوريه
تقارير حقوقيه تصدر يوميا محذرا من اوضاع
المعتقلين احدثها ما نشرته لجنه متابعه
اوضاع المحتجزين التي اكدت الاقيها
معلومات عديده عن اجراء محاكمات عبر
الانترنت للمتظاهرين المحتجزين ليس ذلك
فحسب اللجنه تنبه من اقتصار تلك المحاكمات
على القاضي والموقوف وما يضاعف من مخاوف
اللجنه المده الزمنيه الوجيزه للمحاكمات
الافت التي تحرم بدورها المحتجزين من اي
فرصه للدفاع عن انفسهم كما تعدم اي امال
امامهم بالتواصل مع محامهم وحتى اللحظه
تصدر احكام الاعدام وسط مخاوف جديه من سعي
نظام الى تنفيذ الاعدام بحقه 26 موقوفا
لديه وفق منظمه العدل الدوليه ورغم
الاذنات الدوليه لما يوصف ببطئ النظام
بالمحتاجين
نقلت وكاله انباء الشطاء حقوق الانسان ان
عدد ضحايا الاحتجاجات منذ ان انطلقت يفوق
500 شخص بينهم نحو 70 قاصر فيما يتجاوز
عدد المعتقلين في سجون النظام 20 الف
ايراني حنان المصري العربيه
قرر المغرب ومنع جميع المسافرين القادمين
من الصين من الدخول الى اراضيه بغض النظر
عن جنسيتهم ابتداء من الثالث من يناير الى
اشعار اخر بسبب تزايد الاصابه بكورنا في
الصين وقال بيان للخارجيه المغربيه ان
الخطوه ستاتي على ضوء تطور الوضعيه
الوبائيه في الصين وبقصد تفادي موجه جديده
من العدوى في البلاد
من جاتها اعلنت كندا ضروره حمل القادمين
اليها من الصين نتائج سلبيه لاختبارات
وباءنا وقالت وكاله الصحه العامه الكنديه
انه يتعين على المسافرين فوق عمر 60 تقديم
اختبار قبل نايتين السلبي قبل المغادره
الى كندا ابتداء من الخامس من يناير وسوف
تنطبق هذه التعليمات على المسافرين
القادمين جوا من الصين او هونج كونج او
ماكاو
اعتمدت كرواتيا العمله الاوروبيه الموحده
واللغه الاجراءات الحدوديه امام حمير
جوازات السفر الاوروبيه وهما محطتان
رئيسيتان لهذه الدوله
الاتحاد الاوروبي قبل نحوي عقد من الزمن
كما انضمت كرواتيا الى منطقه شينك التي
تطيح لاكثر من 400 مليون شخص التنقل بلا
تاشيره من بين دولها التي ارتفع عددها
بدخول كرواتيا الى 27 دوله ويقول خبراء ان
اعتماد اليورو سيسهم في دعم اقتصاد
كرواتيا في وقت يسجل تضخم ارتفاعا في
انحاء العالم
في بريطانيا وضعت العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه في عام 20 22 اطول
ذلك صفحه الملكه اليزابيث بعد ثلاثه اشهر
فقط من احتفالها باليوبيل البلنتي لاول
مره ومع تولي الملك تشارلي قياده شؤون
العرش تبدا مرحله جديده يبدو انها بدايتها
لم تكن سهله على الملك الجديد الذي تنتظره
تحديات عائليه وملكيه ينقلها معه للعام
الجديد
وارجوان
[موسيقى]
تليفزيونيه تشرد اسرار قصر
الجديد بوجه اخيه انتقادات لاذعه للصحافه
البريطانيه وبرود وعلاقته نساء العائله
ببعضهم
وثائقي هاري وماجن سلب العائله الملكيه
الخصوصيه التي طالما ميزت ثقافه الانجليزي
في العصر الحديث
ماتت الملكه صاحبه اطول فتره عرش موت شكل
صدمه للبريطانيين رغم انه متوقع لملكه
عاشت 96 عاما
ايام طويله من الحزن وماتم ملكي مهيب شهده
العالم باعجاب ودهشه
وفي حضره الموت توحدت العائله الملكيه
ووضعت فضائحها جانبا
[موسيقى]
رحله الملكه اليزابيث لكي لا تكون شهيده
على عداء الاشقاء حفيدها الامير هاري
القريب على قلبها من جهه والمؤتمن على
استمراريه العرش ولي العهد الامير وليام
من جهه اخرى
شيرز فور هيزمان
ماتت الملكه وعاش الملك ما تم اليزابيث
زاد من شعبيه عائشه وعاد لي يذكر بقله
بريطانيا العظم وتاريخها
لم يكن عام 2022 حزينا ففي يونيو اجل
الستار عن حقبه الملكيه احتفظت فيها
الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه بعرش بريطانيا
مده تجاوزت 70 عاما متصله لتكون اول وريثا
للعرش البريطاني تحتفظوا باليوبيل
للبلاتينيه في مسابقه تاريخيه حرس
البريطانيون على ان يكون جزء منها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
روميا بالبيض اكثر من مره ولكنها لم تكن
اسوء تجاربه كملك جديد فقد اعتاد الازمات
مثل منع الاميرين هاري وانجو من ارتداء
الزي العسكري في المراسم الجنائزيه وتعليق
مهام الامير انجل ملكيه بسبب اتهامات تحرش
ومن ثم اتهامات بالعنصريه طالت عرابه ولي
العهد
التاريخيه هز العائله الملكيه البريطانيه
صحيح انها اعتادت على الفضائح والازمات
لكن فيما تتفتح سنه 2023 اولى صفحاتها
البيضاء على الملك تشارلز ان يكتب تاريخا
جديدا يحافظ فيه على عائلته من لندن عروب
عبد الحق العربيه
منذ سنوات تاسيسها الاولى تسببت فرق مشجعي
كره القدم المتطرفين في فوضى ارهقه
السلطات الروسيه الا ان العمليات العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا ادابت الخلافات بين
المشجعين الامر الذي تجسد في انشاء فرقه
اسبانيولا العسكريه التي تشارك في المعارك
شقه اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
[تصفيق]
مناطق مختلفه من العالم تستقبل عاما
ميلاديا جديدا وتودع عام 20 22 المطرب
[موسيقى]
مع دخول العام الجديد سفره الانذار تدوي
في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا للتحذير من غاره
جويه
كوريا الشماليه تستهل العمل الجديد باطلاق
صواريخ باليستياب تجاه كوريا الجنوبيه
ونبقى معكم في متابعه الملفات الاخباريه
بعد قليل نتواصل معكم في نشره اخباريه
جديده ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]